they got him ladies and gentlemen the
individual who leaked the papers from
the Pentagon about what was going on in
Ukraine and there's some really
interesting details now now that it's
confirmed that this is just apparently
some 21 year old dude who was anti-war
and was trying to impress his friends it
basically confirms that what's in these
papers is real and what does that mean
it's all in all likelihood Russia is
actually winning and the U.S does have
Personnel on the ground that's right U.S
Special Forces confirmed on the ground
in Ukraine well how about that but not
just the U.S a whole bunch of other
countries too so we're gonna have to
jump into that one and uh oh boy U.S on
the ground do you think Russia looks at
what's happening there and says we're
not at war with the West when the West
actually has Intelligence and tactical
support working in that country in their
war against Russia